Michael Kohn is lying he's a weak person
and what he's trying to do is get a
reduced sentence we were thinking about
building a building I decided ultimately
not to do it even if he was right it
doesn't matter because I was allowed to
do whatever I wanted to the campaign he
is afraid of the truth and doesn't want
Muller or anyone else to uncover it if
anything the president has said is true
that there's no there there
why are all his closest associates being
found guilty of lying about their ties
to Russia surprised us but we're told
that the White House know about a
Wednesday night Deputy Attorney General
Rob Rhodes Rosen Stein knew about it on
Monday that Michael Cohen was going to
appear in court and plead guilty to
lying to Congress US vs Michael Cohen
court filing Cohen made false statements
to both the House and Senate
intelligence committees to one minimize
links between the Moscow project this is
the Trump project in Moscow potential
and individual one Trump and to give
false impressions that the Moscow
project ended before the Iowa caucuses
in the very first primary in hopes of
limiting the ongoing Russia
investigations the Moscow project was
discussed multiple time within the
company times within the company and did
not end in January 2016 instead as late
as approximately June 2016 Cohen and
individual two who believed to be Felix
aider discussed efforts to obtain
Russian governmental approval for the
Moscow project now back in January of
2017 President Trump tweeted this he
also talked about it but he tweeted this
Russia has never tried to use leverage
over me I have nothing to do with Russia
no deals no loans no nothing let's bring
our panel formal White House press
secretary Ari Fleischer Susan page
Washington bureau chief at USA Today a
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist okay Ari your impressions of
today how significant what it means for
the president and the Malheur
investigation well you know as Charles
Krauthammer used to say this this feels
like a cover-up of something that is not
a crime there is no underlying issue
here that would require somebody if we
make somebody think they need to lie
what difference does it make if this
project ended in January of 2017 or
January 2016 or June of 2016 so what
when Michael Cohen lies about it what's
the purpose what's the motive and I
can't see any motive here why would he
do it there's no underlying crime
there's nothing wrong with a president
it may be unsavory for a person running
for the president to do business deals
abroad while they're running for
president but it's not a crime Susan if
you if you want to know whether
President Trump thinks this is a serious
issue just look at this response which
has been quite agitated and he clearly
thinks this is a serious story and I
think there's a big difference between
January and June actually because by
June it was clear that Donald Trump was
going to be the Republican nominee for
president and at that time his personal
lawyer is reaching out to a Kremlin
official for help on a private business
deal at a time the Russians are also
have a concerted effort to meddle in our
presidential election to hurt Hillary
Clinton and help Donald Trump that is a
web that is being revealed by by a
special counsel Moeller it's not over
yet this isn't the last disclosure
brunet going to have but it seems to me
that that is a troubling set that's a
troubling context to look at today's
plea deal Molly just worth remembering
that the special counsel was set up to
investigate treasonous collusion with
Russia to steal an election not to
investigate whether Donald Trump is a
global businessman and was doing
business in the year 2016 it is good
though to hold people accountable for
lying to Congress it is a very bad thing
to do and it's been unfortunate that
we've seen so few people held
accountable for lying to Congress even
in this Russia story for instance
Christopher Steele who built the entire
Russia dossier was referred by the head
of the Senate Judiciary Committee almost
a year ago because they knew he lied to
the FBI
Glenn Simpson gave testimony he's the
guy who was hired by Hillary Clinton to
set up the whole Russia story he gave
testimony that was at odds with what
Bruce or gave meaning that one or both
of them lied to Congress so it's
important to everybody be held
accountable for lying to federal
officials it's not even just them you
look at James clapper who lied about
lied to Congress about spying on
everyone John Brennan who lied to
Congress about spying on Congress
Hillary Clinton who lied about whether
she knew how classified systems work
in her interview with the FBI so holding
people accountable for lying is a good
thing it should be done
overall sure there's no donald trump's
nod at the time january 2017 under oath
as he's tweeting that he had no ties no
nothing no loans obviously he's not
under oath when he's telling the
reporters that he had nothing ever to do
with russia but he didn't have business
deals with russia
well it didn't develop but it was being
discussed as it continued on until june
as opposed to january my point is is
that is there something here as far as
money you know we don't know to which a
bank did a lot of his deals they got
rated for the Panama papers today
there's no tangential we don't know that
it's tied at all but if there's a money
link here is it beyond then lying to
Congress and and its whole Russia
holding something over Donald Trump's
head but I think you just use the magic
words we should all abide by we don't
know we don't know and the problem I
have with this town is when people don't
know it doesn't stop them from talking
they make the worst accusations they can
make against people in public life who
they do not like even if they do not
know any the underlying facts is what
Senator Schumer did today which is what
Senator Warner did today what I'm saying
to you I'm asking you where potentially
could it go I'm not willing to speculate
because only Bob Muller will know that
and I don't think any of us should try
to put ourselves in Muller's shoes and
speculate it's one way or another if
Mulder's got the goods Muller will
deliver the goods and will judge at that
time if he doesn't this town owes Donald
Trump a huge apology for two years and
is there a sense Susan in this town that
it's coming to a head that it comes
before Christmas perhaps I I think there
is a sense that Robert Muller seems to
be closer and closer to making a report
on some aspects of his investigation his
investigation is not going to end then
but the aspects involving President
Trump most directly that we've been so
curious about the you know there's
something else is going to happen in
January and that is Democrats in the
house are going to gain the power to
have hearings and demand testimony and
subpoena documents and
the the question you just raised about
didn't Russia launder money through the
Trump organization that's been one of
the things that's been speculated about
that is a specific issue that Adam
Schiff the new chairman of the House
Intelligence Committee said today he is
going to start pursuing as soon as he's
able malin we don't start with finding
we don't say here's the person find me
the crime we look for crimes and then we
determine what what should be done about
it and there has been so much crazy
speculation without any evidence of a
crime and yet we actually have evidence
of all sorts of criminal things like
criminal leaking of classified
information against Trump officials
lying to a FISA Court all sorts of
problems like this that aren't even
being worried about by people who think
well if we just keep digging maybe we
can finally get Trump how about we deal
with actual crimes and start
investigating those I'm going to play
this this protection of the special
council Muller first from the Minority
Leader now Chuck Schumer this idea that
we don't need to pass legislation to
protect the special counsel because
there's no way President Trump will
interfere with the investigation
is flat-out absurd our job here should
be to protect robert muller so that he
can do his job and he can do his job not
for him but for the american people
Bob Muller has been left alone I think
he's gonna continue to be left alone
if I was really really stressed about
Bob Miller I'd do something I'm not
worried about Bob Muller
all right the president has said he's
not firing Bob Mullin Matt Whitaker has
said he doesn't have any plans to get
rid of Bob modern but there is really an
effort on Capitol Hill to protect Bob
Muller from what I mean if Donald Trump
in acting Attorney General Whitaker were
threats to the Mahler probe then why did
Bob Muller indict get the plea agreement
with Michael Cohen they had no problems
getting that no one's interfering with
him no one's cutting his budgets no he's
even gonna say you're laid off in case
the government closes down so it's a
unconstitutional move in the first place
which is why I oppose it if somebody who
used to work in the White House
Congress does not have the power to tell
the president you can or cannot fire
somebody who was a inferior officer in
the object-- executive branch so it's
unconstitutional and I don't know how
you can say you're trying to defend Bob
Muller and the Constitution by passing
an unconstitutional law